it's time for the lawn gene conosco a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene wit nor
watch company maker of lon gene the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene Cronus coat Larry loser from the
CBS television news staff and Kenneth
Crawford national affairs editor for
Newsweek magazine our distinguished
guest for this evening is the honorable
Herbert H Lehman united states senator
from New York senator Lehmann you're one
of the most outspoken of the Liberal
Democrats in Congress what are your
ideas about the legislative program for
the next section of the 83rd Congress
well mr. Lussier I think that there is
many important and vital issues before
Congress this year is I've ever known
there among others there's the
taft-hartley Act the appropriations for
our defense reciprocal trade and other
foreign trade questions foreign aid
atomic energy taxation water power those
are just the main issues there many
others are very great importance to now
I believe that if the president
demonstrates real leadership and if he
approaches these important questions in
a spirit that is influenced as little as
possible by politics we may have a
useful session otherwise I think we will
accomplish very little or nothing what
do you think this is going to be a time
of crisis do you really what you think
foreign aid for example should be cut
back I do not I certainly do not i think
that are one of the most important
things that we can possibly do is to
help our allies abroad the other free
nations are strengthen themselves
economically
and in the military way if we don't
we're going to find ourselves quite
alone it's in this fight against the
totalitarian dozen what about our
defense position now senator leave in
the do you think you approve of the
cutbacks and our budget there but I
certainly very strongly disapproved of
the cutbacks last year i voted against
them particularly the cutback of five
billion dollars for our Air Force
because I felt the Air Force and our air
power was the most important part of our
defense i voted against them and i spoke
against him on the floor of the Senate
now this year I certainly hope that
we're not going to allow our desire for
a balanced budget important as that is
to influence our appropriations for the
fence because it's not going to do us
the least bit of good if we have a
balanced budget and haven't got
sufficient offense to defend our country
and the security of our country and so I
very much hope that we are going to make
appropriations adequate for our events
in every way and I particularly want to
emphasize our air defense senator I
certainly shall work and vote for such
appropriations senator you have been one
of the leaders in and the whole matter
of civil rights legislation you've got
nowhere in the last session I believe do
you think you stand any better chance in
this session I don't know I've been very
much disappointed as a matter of fact
that our president has not made his
position clear on civil rights and has
not urged the adoption of a civil rights
program is country what specific
measures the oven mind senator when you
sell I would have liked to have seen him
speak out on
Fair Employment Practices Act various
matters that affect and result in
discrimination against minority groups
would have liked to have seen him go
through with what he promised to do in
the campaign other words take every
possible means of bringing about a
revision of the McCarran Walter act
you've been a fierce critic of that the
McCarran Walters Immigration Act now do
you think it should be amended or would
you would put an entire substitute bill
in well some of my associates and I
eight senators and 24 congressmen have
put in a bill they'll bears my name but
it's the joint effort oh great many
different members of Congress which is a
complete revision of the of the McCarran
Water Act now I want to be perfectly
frank with you mr. so I think the
McCarran Water Act is a bad bill bad act
and should be revised all there should
be an enlightened shul main practicable
and workable bill passed as a substitute
for the McCarran aight i said to mr.
Crawford a minute ago that I had hoped
that the President of the United States
would back up his pledges during the
campaign and recommend very substantial
revisions he has not done so I hope he
will do so I still have such confidence
in him in his integrity that I i I'm
hopeful that he will if he doesn't and
unless there is a change in the climate
i am very frank to say that in my
opinion there is very little chance of
getting through Congress of the United
States at the coming session a drastic
revision of the McCarran Water Act it's
going to come just as sure as the Sun
will rise tomorrow morning I know that
well speaking of i'm not sure that it's
going to come this yup unless we have
powerful help in support of our position
i was about to say that speaking of the
political climate what are your views
sir
the procedures of the Senate
investigating committees I think you've
had some remarks on that well I've made
quite a few remarks various times let me
let me let me answer this way if I may
some little in Mesilla sir I fully
appreciate as every American must the
need of safeguarding our internal
security I have fought communism for a
great many years just as I fought Nazem
fascism and all other forms of
totalitarianism and we must not relax
our vigilance for a moment against
internal civilian but at the same time
we must not indulge in vigilantism our
issue so far as I am concerned is not
McCarthy as an individual the issue far
transcends any one man or a small group
of men it relates to the campaign which
has been carried on for a year or a year
and a half of fear of intimidation of
calumny vilification guilt by
association and destruction of
reputation it has been an attack not
only on large numbers of patriotic
Americans such as President Truman
general Marshall secretary artisan
Jessup and ambassador Bolin but also on
our great institutions educationalist
solutions schools and colleges and it is
sought to intimidate the press the stage
the publishing world and our great
churches even our great churches and by
it's unfair procedures and techniques it
has caused disunity at home distrust
abroad and through intimidation it is
paralyzed most of our great government
service and a sought to enforce complete
orthodoxy and rigid conformity and
everything that we do or think about
Senator that's why I'm against
McCarthyism senator what about Attorney
General Brownells operations how do you
feel about that and about the
legislation he proposed to proposes
about wiretapping let me say this
Crawford that I feel very deeply that
the recent use and partial disclosures
of secret police
files was bye-bye Attorney General
Darnell the FBI files was unwise
improper and dangerous and I've said so
publicly many times you know in the
white case in the white case the files
of the FBI are filled largely with
unsworn material from confidential
sources even with gossip and hearsay as
we all know most of which is impossible
quite impossible to prove and which the
FBI does not even pretend to evaluate
these files and their contents have
always been secret and in violet less
they lose their usefulness but in spite
of that the Attorney General saw fit to
use and disclose disclose a selected
thought of one particular FBI file in
order to make an attack on the previous
administration that I believe sets a
most dangerous precedent certainly if an
attorney general is Duty it is to
enforce exact justice may publicly
disclose secret police files on one
individuals for his own purpose and may
Moraga disclose only such parts of these
files as suit his purpose and at the
same time with all other parts then in
my opinion mr. Crawford no one in this
country is safe from attack and against
such attacks defense is difficult if not
impossible I assumed under I'd like to
go ahead a bit look in the future do you
think that domestic or international
issue is going to be the key to next
year's congressional elections I don't
know I think it's much too early to
judge that I think it all depends on
what happens in Congress this year I
think the people of the United States in
whose intelligence and judgment I have
the utmost confidence are going to
decide they'll decide the election next
year on the issues as they arise it's
not possible really to divide internal
and a domestic and foreign issues
completely because they are closely
interrelation defense britain's Foreign
Trade
even this issue of McCarthyism they're
all have a relationship in both fields
of our of our life and I believe that we
can't today say that we're going to
elect a president or electric Congress
on the basis of one narrow
classification of issues I think that
people are going to do their own
thinking is they always have done and
I'm going to decide on the issues as
they are presented to them as a final
question senator leave I like to ask you
this you've been a successful
businessman here in New York even a
philanthropist you've been a governor of
New York State and now you're the
representative New York in the Senate of
the United States and do you feel that
there's a special fascination about this
great city at this time when Christmas
time and all the trees of Park Avenue
were lighted up web minister I'm 75
years old I was born in the city of New
York with in almost a stone's throw of
this studio the house in which I was
born was built by my father in 1876 was
torn down two or three weeks ago New
York always has had a fashion
fascination for me and I think it's the
greatest city in the world and I think
the people are the greatest people in
the world it's made up of a
cross-section of all the nationalities
in the world men and women will work
together who live together in Amity
understanding sympathy and goodwill I
think maybe there's a gayest spirit in
the ad at the Christmas season then
ordinarily thank you very much will a
demon spread out and I hope it's spread
out spreads out throughout the entire
world thank you very much Saracen a
great pleasure to have you here tonight
thank you very different you hurt our
speakers express tonight have been
entirely their own the editorial board
for this edition of the lawn gene krona
scope was Larry loser and Kenneth
Crawford our distinguished guest was the
Honorable her bday Sleeman united states
senator from New York